[Music]
excuse me everybody coming through got a
big adventure happening right now
there you go excuse me excuse me
everybody
this guy's brother is going to die
imminently out of the way please he's
trying to clear a path that's all I'm
doing he's gonna be fine
we go
[Music]
okay so these bricks it is floating here
just popping this pipe we're on our way
the only way to fly man
oh wow
oh here we are Palace doors
[Music]
where am I oh fresh meat for the grinder
pay him no heed
but he is
gotta be a way out of here there's no
escape the only hope is the story relief
of death don't do got to be kidding me
my Army Koopas Goombas whatever those
things are oh
we will destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to
save him yes
yes you asked for it this is fun
all right here we
go
foreign
[Music]
thank you Super Mario Bros it seems like
the only thing you haven't drained is my
bank account
for Super Service call or text Super
Mario Bros Plumbing today at
92955 Mario or reach us on the world
wide web at smbplumbing.com
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God okay
all right
you got the cat box oh my I'm sorry okay
now you die
[Music]
foreign
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing an identical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're
oh I got this no problem
yes
come on Marielle our big adventure
begins now ah get it off get it up get
it off
there's a huge Universe out there
there's a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
no pressure
thank you
[Music]
foreign
that is but a taste of our Fury
do you yield
I do not
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
foreign
[Music]
what is this place
do not touch that mushroom you'll die oh
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
[Music]
laughs